video starts guys i've come together
with montana 8 to help those who have
lost their sight to see again may allah
give you guys that clear sight in the
hereafter that you have enabled people
to see in this life inshallah please
donate in the link below assalamu
alaikum brothers and sisters and dear
friends i really wanted to do this video
i didn't really get a chance for this
past week we've been working very very
heavily uh with the marriage documentary
alhamdulillah uh but that's a different
story uh this is a story that's
saddening and we're gonna touch upon
some stuff some
who was the previous imam at the masjid
of mecca
was arrested and sentenced to 10 years
what did he say
that caused him to be arrested here is a
clip of the sermon that he said which
led to his arrest and sentence of 10
years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't believe it's permissible
um i'm not someone to say that the
person who does it is an innovator i
know anybody said that's a whole
different discussion but i believe it
brings more
uh chaos
than um order so i don't really believe
in that now
nowhere did the shaykh ever mention
about
rebelling against a ruler but he has a
right to enjoin the good of the evil
which allah has clearly told us and it's
very important because allah says in the
quran israel that he told them not to
fish in the sabbath group of them when
they started still fishing in the
sabbath not listening to allah's orders
there was three categories of scholars
say the first one was those who saw them
doing that and they didn't say anything
about it
the other one was the ones who saw it
and spoke out against it okay and there
was the other one which you know
basically they promoted or they just
said like no problem they're gonna do
whatever so the ones that spoke out
against it the ones that were silent and
the ones that were just
pro okay now the point is this guys when
it comes to enjoying the good good and
forbidden evil allah said let there rise
amongst you a group of people who will
enjoy good and forbid evil okay
so the sheikh is doing exactly that now
allah subhanahu wa tala destroyed the
ones that fished at the sabbath but the
scholars say the ones who were watching
and not doing nothing about it were also
destroyed why because they were the
silent devil it is very very crucial for
us as believers to enjoy good and
favorite evil because if you don't you
see society perpetually going down the
route of haram because nobody is coming
and saying stop if i see a brother and
sister in a haram relationship listen
and i feel shame and they don't feel
shame doing the act and i feel shame
approaching them this is a disaster if
we can go and approach them at least
they will be shy to not do that again in
public
bro i i don't mean to be rude or
anything but i think you're going to
miss the prayer and you still haven't
prayed
do you see how profound it is to
enjoying good of a bit evil to
senses the sheikh just by saying
allah free mixing conscience and all
this kind of stuff and telling them
reminding them of allah subhanahu talaha
and he gets 10 years in prison
is sickening it's disgraceful and it
shows where the kingdom of saudi arabia
is going i'm not saying every single
person in saudi arabia believes this
some are silence i'm a choir i'm not
asking anybody to come and rebel but the
least we can do is enjoying the god of
the evil from the evil with our circles
it's very very sad and we ask allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala like when i think it
was
he was imprisoned and he said what can
you do to me when my jannah is in my
heart
you can lock him up because he has that
connection with his lord and we ask
allah subhanahu wa make it easy on him
and that he gets closer to his lord in
the serving of this ten years unjustly
and his reward is with allah he didn't
ask for rebellion all he did was enjoy
the buddha with the evil and we should
all do that it's a sad reality that we
live in and it shows us the signs of the
day of judgment that's coming closer
turn to your lord brothers and sisters
to have and i finish on this to have
somebody be a friend be a neighbor be a
family member or somebody who's your
imam that is reminding you of allah and
then you need to feel allah is the best
person that you can have in your life
from sisters
until next time assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi